you ever see the did you see the mic
tweet
wait the guy uh from logan's paw
impulsive oh what do you mean
what do you say
he uh he he tweeted out
and he was like uh damn so we're all
broke now when the crypto crash happened
and then someone replied and they're
like how's your you know six-figure
board ape now and then you replied he's
like i like the art yeah i saw that i
saw that it's just the monkey it's just
the just looks like dk on the mario kart
64 loading screen damn just you know i
saw i saw some [ __ ] where it was like i
don't i don't know if it's true but
someone said that bordeaux tried to
start a dating app and they canned it
because it was just all dudes
no way really it's all the crypto broke
for sure would be
well that's how i bought it yeah here it
is right here so we're all poor
how does that 700k
feel now i bought it because i like the
artwork
yeah
dodge taxes whatever yeah v con went
well
i hope it was a fun time yeah i mean i
just it's just a funny concept to me
just everyone in one thing like
conferences or conventions like this
especially this kind it's like comic-con
or there's something like tangible that
people are like
attaching themselves to
costumes that you can wear and [ __ ] like
that but this is just like we're just
here for pictures on the web yeah yeah
we're here because of to celebrate jpegs
yeah a technology that's been around for
[ __ ] 15 20 years yeah well hopefully
we'll be richer than everyone else with
our jpegs yeah it's just it's web 3 guys
for pictures no you guys going to
[ __ ] get it dude
oh a convention for pictures bro listen
to your [ __ ] self
listen to yourself dude have you ever
been to an art gallery
they have that there they have like just
like the blown up board apes on the
walls that's like moma
i'm sure they did but there are like nft
galleries oh that's great it exists
people pull out their phones they're
like hey no no this is mine no pictures
enough
stop it
damn great have you heard of crypto
island yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
that's my dream
trying to join up to go there yeah
why do you think i put everything in the
luna
i'm trying to hop on
dude i want to see all these like crazy
moments from v con like a marriage
proposal dude was there actually let's
get it no way
that's a real thing that happened
oh no
[Applause]
[Applause]
i couldn't think of a better place to
reject a marriage proposal
in a half-filled stadium about nfts
for an event by nfts you know you want
to propose me here
like a little screen yeah
yeah yeah yeah
instead of a diamond
i got you something that appreciates
yeah like because diamonds you know
they're unethical but crypto kitties are
forever
what else do we got at the
at the v con
v on these nuts
my name is gary vaynerchuk
series two why did he invite us to do
this [ __ ] okay i just want to say if
someone's [ __ ] gratitude okay
i just gave him 17 garage sales because
he doesn't actually like us yeah that's
true
you guys have talked to him right yeah
yeah yeah you guys
no i'm sure i'm sure gary is a
billionaire he likes everyone is he
billionaire billionaire he's about to be
yeah the b yeah
still yeah i think so even after the
crash i think so
it's a lot of money yeah
uh invested in twitter right and
facebook
yeah maybe like it was like three of the
main tech companies super early yeah
yeah gary
gary knew what he was doing he came on
for a bit um
we had a strict
guideline for that discussion
yeah it was harsh no it was just like it
was basically like if you're gonna do
anything fun don't even [ __ ] think
about it
we'll end this zoom call before you you
can even get the joke off yeah and then
i'll sue your ass for everything you
want yeah and then you know so then we
kind of had like this like softball
interaction with him and then people
were like
way to give a [ __ ] scammer a platform
dude we're like
he's kind of bigger than us so
i don't think we can i don't think you
can really call him a scammer
can you you don't get to a billion with
a b if you don't scam a little bit man
there's no way but hey what's wrong with
just a little bit yeah
yeah yeah just to get to the place
yeah okay yeah i've been there
you know but this is real like
you know yeah
that's about i would never [ __ ] go in
my entire life but yeah no that's
definitely yeah that's valuable
this is this is art yeah
seeing a wedding proposal live at a half
empty stadium at v con yeah this looked
like my
uh late st louis show on friday
yeah why why that's like one of the
first shows i haven't done in a minute
that wasn't like to the back of the room
it was actually kind of badass though it
was just like 100 people and i'm like
i'm gonna just say the worst [ __ ] in
here perfect crowd for st louis yeah no
no i wouldn't say that yeah i would not
say that the chill they have the uh
pyramid right the archery thing no
honestly i mean no the fish pyramid
fish pyramid look at that the largest
fish pyramid bass pro fishing shop
no if i had known that i would have gone
yeah it's like a mecca sick
it's like a pyramid it looks like the
luxer
you fish
not once ah i know me neither but i kind
of what into the holy [ __ ] it actually
looks like the luck sir yeah
god damn it damn where were you when i
needed you
could have brought you there
at least told me about it you buy guns
there
absolutely you can yeah definitely
you can buy it
right on the water so like it's what you
see when you come into oh come on dude i
would have um i would have been in there
do you think carrot top performs
every night for a price dude every night
at the bass pro
st louis that's why i didn't sell out
that the the friday late show because
they were at it they're at carrot top at
the
yeah
i have to say though best shows i've had
so far shout out st louis really yeah
why